welcome back to CBS mornings and so many
people want to fly these days at the
airlines hired nearly 50 000 new
employees last year but the industry is
struggling to find enough qualified
Pilots by some estimates Airlines
worldwide could be 60 000 Pilots short
by the end of the decade that's prompted
United Airlines to take a new approach
organizing its very own training course
Chris Van Cleave takes to the skies to
see how it's going
and we're flying
Ricky Foster's dream of becoming an
airline pilot is really taking off after
completing basic pilot training outside
Phoenix I feel like an eagle up here
like you're soaring I feel like I'm
sorry we first met the former flight
attendant and mother of two last year
when she was among the 51 future flyers
in the inaugural class of United's
aviate Academy it's part of the
airline's effort to address the
continued pilot shortage and diversify a
Workforce that is overwhelmingly white
and male this first graduating class is
80 percent woman or minority
your graduating class looks nothing like
a flight school anywhere else no it
looks nothing like the industry but
guess what it does look like it does
look like the demographic we serve it
looks like our passengers airlines are
hiring thousands of employees as travel
demand has roared back from pandemic
lows Josh azuha left his job as a Denver
area police officer to attend aviate the
next step for me is to instruct here at
the United Academy as a flight
instructor and build my hours before
ultimately hopefully transitioning to
the Airlines and there'll likely be a
job waiting for him United expects major
U.S carriers will need 10 000 new pilots
this year alone but only have about 6
600 qualified candidates the cost and
years of training to become an airline
pilot discourages many people despite a
potential six-figure salary basically
you either had to go through the
military or you needed to have access to
someone willing to give you a 100 to 150
000 to get through all the training it's
just a huge barrier to entry CEO Scott
Kirby says United is the first major U.S
carrier to start its own flight school
does aviate get you out of that pilot
crisis Aviation is not going to
certainly in the short term there's
still four to five years away from
showing up for their first day in a
United Airlines cockpit but it is the
right kind of long-term answer to not
just solving the pilot shortage but
creating good careers for people and
giving people access to careers that can
be life-changing for them their families
and their communities you are my first
passenger new pilot Ricky Foster hopes
to swap this small plane for a United
Flight Deck Landing her dream gig within
the next few years for CBS mornings I'm
Chris Van Cleave in Phoenix
man I tell you what if I'm sitting like
a bump on the couch thinking about what
my next move is flight schools great
option very cool
I want somebody that knows what they're
doing though well they're going to get
five minutes that's what they're doing
that but everyone's a student at some
point yeah they were trained and like
they're out like they're dreaming about
being a pilot there's a program that
gets them into that this is an exciting
partner you may not have thought of and
that's what I'm saying it looks like a
great program I get it I agree with you
Tony thank you United thank you